was was warum warum ich bin kein hacker
leute was soll die scheiße los geht so
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
wie spiel heute eine runde 64 er ist
aber viel wichtiger ist heute relativ
leer und ich glaube dass eisenstadt
nicht scheeßel
es ist eigentlich nur wieviel 18 er ist
glaube ich und ich habe keine waffe auf
steht ja eben aber noch keiner genau
schön gut gefällt hier noch nicht es ist
18 sg essen tatsächlich 18 leute auf
dieser 64er web das heißt aber dass es
eine richtig richtig heftige equipment
schlacht wird weil alle sich das
übertrieben statement einsammeln können
nur ich nicht weil ich immer die
falschen wege gehen aber prinzipiell was
ich euch sagen will ist ist diese runde
sicher knackig wird es werden sicher
einige hier relativ schnell richtig
cooles zoll kam und auch wenn es relativ
wenig leute sind für die große map wird
es auf jeden fall spannend würde ich mal
sagen weil dann kann man mal das ganze
gut mit einsetzen was man sonst
vielleicht nicht hat und wahrscheinlich
jeder überlegen gold april heiltränke
feuerzeug und dann ist man equipment
technisch relativ gleich aufgestellt
aber manchmal etwa die überall schon
leute wie guck mal hier hatte da war
schon einer im raumschiff vielleicht
schon im millennium falcon mit schrecken
immer kurz verhindert
was macht ein schwert mit dem
mittelalter die zweite flasche mal so
richtig unnötig richtig unnötiges teil
die vol die schauten video die flasche
und der wein an
das eine zeigt dann musst du mich so
sehr beleidigt warum wie unnötig diese
leute draußen ist aber egal wir kunden
mit dem fachwissen weiter ich glaube
hier ging es recht sommerrain 36 so weit
haben wir glaube ich alles geholt so gut
ist denn auch kein aber vielleicht muss
ich die augen offenhalten kompass sehr
sehr gut das ist echt extrem wichtig ist
mein kompass hat weil sonst findet man
die leute nicht erfreue sich nach dem
ersten stern
amore mio
hast du vielleicht ein bogen oder sonst
etwas was ich gebrauchen könnte der
sieht will auf jeden fall ein feuerzeug
das ist schon mal sehr gut hat sich
jetzt aber nicht eingesetzt und zwei
getränken eis aber keinen bogen
egal vielleicht er hat auf jeden fall
ein bogen mich mal sagen ich verzichte
mich nicht dass ich mich nicht dass ich
nicht auch sehr schön wunderbar für
mitgenommen jetzt will er auch noch mal
weg sehr geil sehr gut sehr gut sogar
jetzt nicht aus den augen lassen wo der
nächste gegner war sehr gut junge so
schnell kann man sich hoch wollen mit
dem equipment würde ich mal sagen wo wir
brauchen auf jeden fall ein eilten chain
am schnellsten fünf liegestütze machen
kommt kommt kommt kommt schnell schnell
schnell die menschenhändler in angie
angie angie angie angie angie angie
chain ich glaube sieht schlecht aus
ich glaube es sieht schlecht aus
wir haben kein stellen wir haben kein
schönherr und wenn wenn ich es ist eine
alte regel dass man zum 0 1 und rüstung
immer tragen muss wenn ich den nicht hat
muss für felix schütz machen
ich mach das mal schnell 133 ich habe
jetzt mal nicht die kamera umgestellt
weil das sonst so einen sohn hackmack
möchte ist mitten in die runde machen
sorry ihr habt jetzt gerade nicht
gesehen sieht nun dass meine haare
bisschen an bord sind danach so ich
stürzte die kopfhörer und nein so gut
dann kann man weiter mit alter dass das
jetzt langsamer so die es regel gibt
schon relativ alt lange gibt schon alt
tatsächlich gerald relativ lange diese
regel dass man sowohl eine rüstung also
zur umrüstung immerhin chain tragen muss
wenn man das nicht macht fünf
liegestütze diese lege schutz regelung
gibt es aber erst seit ich irgendwie mal
angefangen habt in einem stream ich
glaube vor zwei drei tagen oder so also
die regel gibt schon schon seit
ewigkeiten aber die strafe
die gibt es erst seit ein paar tagen und
ja wenn man software switch machten auf
youtube machen alte regel im internet im
internet galilei was ich hatte ja einen
käse erzähle heute man aber so weit auf
die runde ganz gut das ist zumindest
schon mal ein kleiner trost guck mal
hier drüben cocktails an durch man ey
wir können uns india schwert kräften
wollen wir aber erst mal gucken ob er
den gegner klatschen wisst ihr was wir
greifen ist ihr schwert so wenig leute
ich will die hunde unbedingt gewinnen
also wie gesagt noch mal ganz bewusst
gewählt hier das eine 64er runde mit
relativ wenigen gegnern kommt denn so
man richtig geiles equipment gerade
gekümmert macht einfach mehr bock zu
zocken da kann man taktischer spielen
man kann vielseitige spielen
man kann auf seine haare ab stehen
lassen es kann man auch aber wie gesagt
nur mit solchen
equipment genau jetzt gehts ums pony
vorne
so ist der nächste gegner kommt aus
schlägt in die richtung aus aber ich
sehe da niemanden
deswegen soll es mir egal sein wer soll
es mir egal sein als heute prägung ich
muss kurz mal überlegen deswegen soll es
mir egal sein
als würde ich mich um mich selbst ein
dreck scheren
ich habe nur die konstruktion gesucht
ich wusste schon sinngemäß was ich sagen
wollte aber mehr hat die construction
gefährt wer auf eine baustelle wo noch
nicht los gelegt wurde hat auf jeden
fall eine gute feuer gelegt würde ich
mal sagen wir haben unser team schwert
kamen so diersch werden auf drei gegner
noch drei gegner hat an werde sal
übrigens leute wenn ihr wollt dass ich
den wahlmodus auf regenzeit mal für euch
an spiele schreibt mir das gerne meine
kommentare ich hab den garten schon mal
angezockt ist dann wahrscheinlich mit
ein bisschen mehr schneider arbeit
verbunden denn die runde dauert halt wie
35 bis 45 minuten oder sogar länger mit
64 runden spielt deswegen müsste man da
ein bisschen mehr karten aber wenn er
bock drauf ob ich das gerne machen also
rein in die kommentare
fribourgs in die kommentare leute ok
danke schön
auch elf eile das ist gut können wir
noch eingeben
na komm zeig dich zeigt sich zeitig a
shit hat nicht gereicht fakt ist aber
auch haushalten anfallen
und es ist diese jenna das ist nicht so
dolle dies relativ klein so die bieten
sich dann hole ich mir den hier
zakk wylde alles leisten wollen hätten
wir nicht so jetzt macht ihr was man dir
tu wann oder wie ja freilich nicht die
jungs muss ich sagen was hacker warum
bin ich jetzt der hacker altig bekennen
warum schreibt ihr immer hacker leute
lasst doch sowas optimistisch sind
gestern der stars die schau mal kurz was
los was ich mit dem was was warum warum
ich bin kein hacker leute was soll die
scheiße alter nein nein
alter schwede sind jörg gemeinsam ihr
richtiges pilz arbeite ich muss erst mal
weinen
aber dann denke ich ein lotse mit
welchen hast dann geht es mir wieder gut
lassen daumen da schneidet den
abwehrmann ihr wisst bescheid wieder das
nächste video wieder in die kommentare
bitte was ihr vom bau heute und danke
für die ganzen kommentare zum letzten
video für die um die ganzen bewerbung
habe ich mich aber gefreut wie gesagt
auflösung mit 24 uhr autor einen job